and now let's hear from the girls do you  think most girls are objective or do you  think they think they're hotter than  they are  or do they underrate themselves go  around personally I think it depends on  the person because growing up I'm  obviously not skinny hi everyone I'm not  skinny so growing up I was never the be  standard for anyone so like all my  friends were getting chatted up by  people blah blah blah blah and I was  just the other one you know so like I  never really thought of myself as  an attractive person like I would never  call myself anything more than a thought  but now like I don't really care about  what anyone thinks about me like I've  grown into myself and I've I've I'm  comfortable with who I am now that like  even if I you guys call me delusion or  whatever I think I'm maybe not 10 let's  not go that far but like definitely an  eight per so like whether you guys think  I am or not